we've been talking a lot about infinite
series and now we're going to talk about
using infinite series to actually define
functions and the most common infinite
series used to define and approximate
functions is a power series
power power
series so i could have a function
f of x defined
as the infinite series so we'll go from
n equals 0 to infinity
of a sub n times x minus c to the nth
power
where a sub n is just the nth
coefficient and c is some constant and x
of course is our variable so this right
over here is a function of x and it
might be a little bit clearer if i
expand this out this is going to be our
zeroth coefficient times x minus c to
the zero power which is of course this
part is just of course equal to 1 so
this would simplify to a sub 0
plus a sub 1 times x minus c to the
first power plus a sub 2 times x minus c
to the second power and we could go on
and on and on and this shows up
throughout mathematics it's often people
will often use a finite number of terms
of a power series to approximate complex
functions and this allows them to do
things in their head it allows them to
get a sense of things it allows them to
operate sometimes on a easier to operate
on functions and this shows up in
electrical engineering and it shows up
even in finance and bond trading bond
traders will actually use a power series
approximation to figure out what a what
a bonds price might do or what the what
the corresponding
implied interest rate on a bond might be
but we're not going to worry about that
right now we're just going to deal with
it a little bit more mathematically
now the one thing that you might see
when you look at this well well you know
isn't is it a geometric series where if
i make the common ratio x isn't that a
special case of a power series and you
would be correct in assuming that so
let's write down a geometric series
where the common ratio is x
so geometric
geometric
series
so let's define a function g of x
as a geometric series where the common
ratio is x
instead of the r that were more typical
more typically used to represent the
common ratio so n equals 0 to infinity
of a times x to the n so what's the
difference between these two things well
this is just a special case we're making
c equals 0 and we're making all of these
a sub 0 a sub 1 a sub 2 they're all just
going to be equal to a
and we know that we can expand this out
as a times x to the 0
plus a
plus a
a times x to the first power plus a
times x squared and we just go on and on
and on forever this is an infinite this
is an infinite series
well we've already seen how we can take
this sum in fact we've already done
multiple examples where we take sums of
infinite series and we've derived the
formula that gets us that this is going
to be equal to a over 1 minus our common
ratio and in this case our common ratio
is equal
is equal to x
what's interesting about this is instead
of going from the sum to kind of or
instead of going from this geometric
series expanded form to what the sum
needs to be we can use this to go the
other way if we can get some functions
into this form we can then expand them
out as geometric series or essentially
we will find their power series
representation because a geometric
series is a special case of a power
series
and to show an example of that
let's take
let's take the function
h of x
h of x is equal to
1 over 3 plus x squared so i encourage
you now to pause this video and try to
rewrite this function in this form right
over here and if you can write it in
this form to then go and write it as a
geometric series
so i'm assuming you've given a go at it
so let's try to do it so we want a 1
right over here and we want to subtract
something so if we want a 1 right over
here let's divide the denominator by 3.
so this is equal to or let's factor out
a 3 i should say 1 over 3
times 1
plus
x squared
x squared
over three all i did here is i factored
out a three i divided three by three
factor it out and then i i factored out
a three from x squared so if i were to
redistribute you would get this again
now i could rewrite this
i could rewrite this as instead of 1
over 3 i could write this as let me
write it this way i could write it as
i could write it as so this part right
over here
i could write as 1 3
over
over
1
and i want to subtract this thing
instead so 1 minus
1 minus and i could write
negative
x squared
negative x squared over 3. notice adding
x squared over 3 is the same thing as
subtracting negative x squared over 3.
so now i've written in this form i have
my a my a would be 1 3 and then my
common ratio x is going to be negative x
squared over 3. so now i can rewrite h
of x i can say that h of x
h of x
is going to be equal to
the infinite series so go from n equals
zero to infinity my a is one third
my a is one third and then my common
ratio
my common ratio
is
negative x squared
negative x squared over three
i'm going to raise that to the nth power
and so if i wanted to expand it out and
actually maybe i'll write that in the
purple if i wanted to expand this out
what would it look like well this would
be this would be equal to well the first
term when n is equal to zero this whole
thing just becomes one so this is going
to become this is just going to be
one-third
and then the next term i'm just going to
multiply by the common ratio i'm going
to multiply by negative x squared over
3. so this is going to be equal to this
is going to be equal to negative
negative so if i take 1 3 and multiply
by negative x squared over 3 that's
going to be negative
x squared over
9.
and then if i were to multiply by
negative x squared over 3 again well now
i'm going to get positive
x
x to the 4th
over
over 27. notice the common ratio every
time to go from here to there i have to
multiply by negative x squared over 3.
to go from there there i have to
multiply by negative x squared over 3
and i could keep going on
and on and on and if i really wanted to
write it in that form i could just let
me let me make this a little bit clearer
so i could just write it as i could just
write this as 1 3
1 3
minus
1 9
times x
times x squared
plus
1 27
times x to the fourth and you might say
well this is almost the same form but
you know all these forms up here we had
right here you just have the x to the
zero term and then the x squared term
what about this well remember you could
just make this coefficient zero so i
could even i could even rewrite it like
this i could say this is equal to one
third
one third times
x to the zero
plus
0 times x to the first power
plus or let me write this minus
1 9
x squared
and then plus
0 times x to the third power
and then plus 1 over 27 times x to the
fourth power and then notice i have this
in the exact same form i have the exact
same form as our original power series
so without using any calculus we were
able to take a function like this
represent it
represent it like this and then find a
power series representation for it and i
would this one i don't want to confuse
you here but you could ignore these
terms because these are just zero and
one of these two is kind of a clean way
of viewing it